bonjour est avec nous accueillent
clémentine célarié et s'enfuit à bientôt
bonsoir connu alors ces temps plus
clément tine oui c'est mon fils à bras
oui ça c'est le petit poucet grand
premier ouais un peu puis un an vous
êtes sur scène avec toute la famille ça
s'appelle mon cabaret way marsa on va
pas en parler pas pourquoi parce qu'en
fait on est vraiment venu pour pour
comment dire pour ce pur pour un truc
pour lequel on s'est retrouvés réunis
tous les deux pour le sida en fait et
est en fait on a fait de la musique tous
les deux on a fait un titre ensemble
pour eux pour le pas ce que parce qu'on
a voulu faire un espèce de baiser
collectif dire j'ai voulu simplement
démultiplier ce baiser que j'avais
donnée à cet homme qui s'appelle patrice
jeanniot il ya 11 ans dans un sidaction
des arrosants le premier et je voulais
le démultiplier parce que comme ça et tu
vois et j'ai pensé qu'il serait plus
fort bon alors c'est un soir chez c'est
dans une émission chez cauet comme sage
et g10 comme ça qu'ils feraient qui
s'embrassent ray sur la bouche l'idée de
s'embrasser solidarité voilà avec un
séropositif et une personnes
séropositive au sirop positive eux et à
ce moment là tout le monde a dit j'ai
dit par exemple c'est comme si on
demandait là tu vois qu'ils seraient là
et puis plein de gens de vue la main et
moi je me suis dit tiens on va faire ce
clip
après ça a été une galère sans nom mais
vraiment sans nom de faire ça parce
qu'en fait une personne sur deux a peur
donc je suis très heureuse qu'on l'ait
fait parce que contrairement aux idées
reçues c'est un truc c'est la moindre
des choses mais en même temps il ya
plein de gens qui ont peur un bon de
faire ça donc on l'a fait grâce à une
femme c'est un clip back rave
il ya eu toute une équipe de gens qui se
sont mises autour avec nous et puis à
bras je dis bon endroit il faut qu'on se
bouge le cul et on a fait un titre tous
les deux et en fait on a fait ça pour le
sidaction et donc c'était il ya eu çà a
été collectivement brichart aurait pu
être là mon nom n'a pas ce que ça s'est
fait très vite dans l'urgence alors là
eu la région ah c'est vrai tu embrasses
mais c'était important parce que
comment dire c'est en même temps c'est
une goutte d'eau au coin on va voir à
quoi ça ressemble c'est le plus simple